si vous ajoutez à cela
le bruit et l'odeur c'est une phrase qui
a fait beaucoup beaucoup de polémiques
le bruit et l'odeur il est à orléans en
train de dîner avec des militants et des
cadres du rpr l'aimé bien être à table
jacques chirac et buvait de la bière
d'ailleurs il ya un verre de bière qui
est qui est à moitié terminé devant lui
il ya une certaine chaleur liés à la fin
du repas et jacques chirac en effet veut
aborder le thème de l'immigration
le travailleur français qui travaille
avec sa femme et qui ensemble gagne
environ 15000 francs et qu'ils voient
sur le pas de pallier à côté de son hlm
entassée une famille
avec un père de famille trois ou quatre
épouses et une vingtaine de gosses et
qui gagne 50 mille francs de prestations
sociales sans naturellement travailler
si vous ajoutez à cela
le bruit et l'odeur
est bien le travailleur français sur le
palier devient fou là on commence en
effet à stigmatiser des des populations
qui pourraient en effet non seulement
être bruyante mais faire une cuisine
particulièrement odorantes et peut-être
mal odorantes et ce n'est pas être
raciste que de dire cela nous n'avons
plus les moyens d'honorer le
regroupement familial
il faut bien savoir que le regroupement
familial c'était en 1976 le chef de
gouvernement le pop qui s'appelait
jacques chirac qui l'avait instaurée qui
a rendu l'immigration visible en france
parce qu'on a vu les femmes dans les
commerces on avait les enfants dans
l'école et pas simplement les hommes qui
allaient à l' usine et là on al
impression qu en une vingtaine d'années
il a beaucoup beaucoup évolué pourquoi
et bien parce que entre temps il y a eu
la percée politique du front national
monsieur chirac a précisé ses propos il
a souligné qu'il fallait sortir de la
langue de bois habituelle au sujet des
immigrés et que monsieur le pen n'avait
pas le monopole de ces thèmes jean marie
le pen a énormément
politiser le débat de l'immigration là
c'est un jacques chirac qui fait de la
copie puisque le lendemain jean marie le
pen 17 une phrase qui ensuite fera c'est
que c'est fou je crois que les électeurs
préféreront toujours
l'original à la copie et là on voit que
au fond jacques chirac qui était un
homme pourtant subtil un vrai humaniste
toute sa carrière le montre eh bien oui
un soir à orléans après quelques bières
ben voilà cède à la xénophobie en cela
hélas il est un homme ordinaire
[Musique]